it's a blink of calm exclusive yos power
98.3 where hip-hop lives man bootleg
camera mo chillin right now man this
kind of a big deal to me because it's
the first hip-hop tape I ever owned in
my life was creeping on a Cove I got all
five members of bomposa harmony in
studio right now
that's right man I remember yo when I
was a kid I used to cop every solo album
thug mentality heaven's movie man
everything man so yo is definitely
harder to have all five you all in the
same room I'm glad to see you guys are
back to working together oh you get the
nature of course man I the bold well
there's all that stuff right oh hey but
I did I did stay away lazy I got all the
high-powered stuff with all the bottle
wrapping I didn't mess with us it was
you know what some man you know I'm
greatly appreciative of it yeah yeah
yeah them are all boys hey so you guys
are are in town man it's the 20th
anniversary of the group correct yes 20
years 20 years anniversary of us
professionally record you've been way
way longer than that you know now is
that included like bone enterprises like
the face is a death joint yeah you gotta
include a bone Enterprise you know I
mean that was our first real major
professional package album that we that
we do yeah I'm saying so that's the
whole span 20 years of us getting it in
man hey so um you guys aren't all going
to be on stage tonight man of course you
guys did Rock the Bells which I saw was
crazy historical um what can people
expect man I mean I know a lot of people
you guys have fans in are like diehard
fans I want to hear like random album
cuts and like random solo records you
guys keeping it pretty pretty simple
with just playing a hit record if we
wanted to Lear by tonight make sure you
dig in your crates before you come to
the show cuz you never know what songs
we're gonna do we want crowd
participation yeah I mean you know it's
all of us man
so we're gonna watch it up you know what
I mean so a lot of songs a lot of songs
may have three or may have four you know
I mean but we don't concentrate
basically on five or five lives and
making sure we all shine as a unit you
know what I mean and give our fans each
one of us that they've been missing
already because last time I think it was
me wishing crane Oh busy didn't meet me
fleshing wish and pray me flesh wishing
busy so you know it's all of us man and
we want to give them as much as we can
before they cut the lights on in the
building you know hey for real like
that's one thing a lot of times you guys
come to certain cities it'll be like
three you guys are for you guys it's
such a big decision so so damn hard to
get all favi on the same place at the
same time like a big deal it matters
that star problem anymore I mean it's
like it's such a monumental event when
we all together man we get so excited to
be around each other we just click mad
for no odd reason just because we fan
them and we family like that but it's
always a monumental event when it's all
five of us it's always some good bread
involved it's always everybody's
individual followers that they follow
everybody all of it together it's
beautiful man you know hey um you guys
of course have gone through you guys is
like you know ups and downs with each
other as far as you know breaking up
getting back together you know what I'm
saying what what is the key to keeping
all five of y'all together you know once
a fraud I think it's honesty and you
know what they don't understand
outside of of what we do is man we
really are like a group like we can
really really talk about each other and
get mad with each other and all that
cool stuff and still not really be hype
you know against each other sometimes
the people around us or the fans or say
see us say something about one of our
brothers and then you know take it upon
themselves to you know act like it's
such a big problem but my buddies can
call me any name in the book I know that
they care about me over and beyond any
name or any of this business stuff and
all of that because when it comes down
to it like lazy always tell me first one
of us that happens to go we go all be
there to carry the cat
asking and that's the only thing that
counsel we got to be together I'm try
that point and care about each other so
that's how we love one another as a unit
and as bros it's like we together until
death like for real for real yo
I know you guys have each kind of had
know your own own like separate kind of
movements on how crazy you had Doug Lyon
you know is that still like is that
still a know the the the indie label
you're pushing to no recipe you've not
change the um I change the name like a
couple years ago to the life
entertainment okay that's basically what
I've been pushing got a clothing line
the life apparel you know and just been
doing all kind of stuff you know like so
I mean you know like the we still got
our you know our individual grind on
what you know when it comes to the bone
situation you know anybody come together
we just man put it in put in the work
and get it done you guys working on a
new any new projects as I know they're
supposed to be art award a new artwork
coming out for I read or maybe that's a
rumor that tend to that's tinted behind
right now we got some new stuff we
working on a couple of ciphers and a
couple of singles and everything as you
know the one with our birdie starry
remix with gang yes and oppression right
we got that and you know even myself
I've been working on the cover that
anything you know I gearing up to UM do
be doing as Vaughn doesn't harm me flesh
bone Globo just released a new uh a
group called the duct tape game on
iTunes right now so our release mixtape
called duct tape everything so it's
pretty cool other than that we've been
focusing on a roll you know kicked off
Rock two bills in the summertime we've
been on the road ever since every
weekend and now we gearing up to get in
there and a crank out some new music
right now we got a lot of stuff brewing
a lot of ideas room right now hey I know
I know when I was like you know when I
was younger I used to always you know we
got to drop DVDs behind the scenes you
guys record albums and stuff you guys
have like a really interesting and cool
process it seems like it's just this is
it's an event to be in the studio with
you guys you know what I'm saying what
is the creative process to have five MCS
you know what I'm seeing five different
personalities to all kind of get on the
same page to do an album or to do a
joint I mean really it's hard now liddie
it ain't really it ain't
our van is um it's natural man is like
we we didn't had the same chemistry
together forward over a couple decades
you know what I'm saying so it's like we
automatically fall into the vibe
ya know there's no telling you know
what's gonna spark an idea you know you
might have crannis studio cores lioness
who fangs would be coming in drop a
verse and you know or just somebody walk
through and say something in my spark a
song so you know it's just energy flying
when you got five creative people as
creative as we are you know I mean it's
like energy is flying off - off the
walls right right in his life when we
did the LOV like pop pop energy max Bone
Thugs and harmony is you know I mean he
he hype off the hood creative we
discussing things we talking about life
was going on in the world you know what
I mean and that's basically where we get
our ideas from man and we want to say
you know wrestling piece there but
everything that happened this morning
yeah for sure I was gonna ask you guys
about that Connecticut you know our
thoughts and prayers go out to them
children cuz that's what we stand for
man we all got kids the evil world
merican and it's terrible out here man
and you know without getting political
you know me we don't see them at the
crossroads man and we're gonna
definitely send that shout-out on stage
tonight for that got to yep cause man
and that nd man indeed um you guys have
works you just mentioned working with
Tupac on you guys alright I want to say
the only artist to do a joint wit POC
and we're biggie
yeah little bit fun - yeah big fun
anything that mr. Jay Andrews J yeah
and he's kind of weird when you think of
ETFs pavia ejj magic pawn pop take us a
quick moan and this - but yeah yeah I
mean what what what was um the the you
know biggie I think a lot of times I
know everyone knows biggie don't write
like he didn't write he didn't write his
you know stuff that down he just got
into the booth and did a stable what was
it like man vibing with him in the
studio I was off the hook man you got
pictures man
you know that immortalizing situation
man but you know it was good man with
everything was green in the studio you
know what I mean big cognac big yeah
trees and everything you know we had a
relationship with big ego you know I
mean from prior things when going to New
York and just seeing them from here and
there and things like that so we was
already forming to reforming a
relationship with him and little sees
the whole Junior MAFIA so we was tired
that's dope man I mean indeed that night
he didn't even read indoors wrapped at
night we actually didn't get to hear it
until after he was deceased man so that
was like the the very first person that
flipped the flow and did is you know hit
his bone he did it both a way and he did
it his way and it was a compliment you
know more so than anything because it
can't because it came from biggie indeed
I think I think I think it's kind of
prevalent too lately man I feel like
there's a lot of artists who kind of
taken like you know the harmonizing and
the singin and all of that like you know
I know crazy I hear I hear crazy bald
influences a lot a new artist um um what
does that like man cuz I know you guys
been in the game 20 years deeply I
really like lately I've been hearing a
lot of you know to me at least I hear a
lot of bone and a lot of these new cats
I mean well I look at it like this you
know it's like after so many years it's
kind of like become a stable staple in
in hip-hop and it's kind of not really
even looked at like bone thugs-n-harmony
really really really started it because
it's so very very accepted and it's kind
of like the secret that everybody knows
but really won't say it or don't want to
give credit or something it's just
really a crazy energy around that whole
thing as opposed to everybody else that
initiates somewhat of a style but at the
end of the day I believe that we all are
happy that it's out there that people
can feed their kids and you know I think
that we've all kind of accepted that
we've done something for hip-hop and
we've added to hip-hop but we haven't
just usurped from the people and just
you know just took their money and
didn't give anything back to the culture
think that we gave something back and
that's how I look at it and I try to
preach it around my family members so we
can all stay on that level but none of
us have no hate in our heart ain't none
of us bitter way mad at these skinny
jeans or not lover you know we ain't
even mad we know what it is in a soiree
or we just want the young cats to grow
so Wistar brothers named it up that I
like a crab on ASAP rocky rocky hates
that
that guy right there is off the hook mr.
Lamar is off you're looking all the
young guys is coming up so we all love
it you know as as artists ourselves you
know that's somebody hm